what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with Doomsday
Clock number seven and this is actually
kind of an interesting scenario here
because what geoff johns does in this
story is he messes with us
he really kind of toys with us a little
bit and it's actually pretty cool it's
kind of cool to see him CMS with things
a bit so what this does is this picks up
with the Green Lantern of Allen Scott
now for those of you guys who don't know
of course this is really kind of where
we left off in the last Doomsday Clock
story and Geoff Johns picking up with
this actually offer some pretty
intriguing things so the first thing I
want to do here is I want to talk about
something called the Justice Society of
America back in the 1940s when you had
like Gardner Fox and those guys who were
really kind of creating you know DC
characters and teams the Justice Society
of America was the first team that DC
had they were the predecessors to the
Justice League it's one of the big
misconceptions that a lot of non
comic-book readers have is that the
Justice League was the first big team
not at all the JSA were really like
small-time characters you had like you
know the the original flash Jay Garrick
the original Green Lantern Ellen Scott
Hawkman different people like that I
think the spectre was part of it at one
point maybe it was dr. fate and then you
got into 1960 with Justice League which
gave us kind of like the second
iteration of the JSA but with a more
popular team now because of the fact
that the original JSA for the 1940s in
in real time the original JSA existed on
earth too which was a different universe
when DC got rid of the multiverse and
what they did is they came back and they
said actually the JSA were World War two
superheroes and so by the time Batman
and Superman and Wonder Woman and
Aquaman by the time they'd risen to
prominence and became superheroes in the
modern era the JSA had basically retired
now DC tried to come back and change
that a little bit but Geoff Johns is
sort of bringing that back in and what
he's doing here is he's really kind of
does it by way of dr. Manhattan talking
to us and it's kind of a big deal with
the original Green Lantern of Allen
Scott it wasn't actually a Green Lantern
per se I mean it was insofar as it was a
red I'm sorry a green meteor the crash
into Earth and it was kind of a lamp
that was turned into a lantern but it
wasn't until after a really you know
much later on in DC Comics that they
actually rolled Alan Scott over into
quote-unquote the Green Lantern Corps
originally his Green Lantern ring was
totally separate from all the other
Green Lantern's that existed out there
and so with regards to this he got you
know Geoff Johns kind of runs through
the origin which is pretty straight
forward but he says small things now
here's the funny thing about this is
that dr. Manhattan says this in a way to
where it doesn't happen in a linear
fashion and that's one thing to keep in
mind right like he doesn't say like in
in nineteen
this happen and in 1950 this happened
and in 1960 that happened he says like
in 1940 this happened and then in 1960
this happened and then in 1950 that
happened dr. Manhattan does not see time
linearly
dr. Manhattan sees everything all at
once he sees the whole span of time
happening all at one time
the difference here is that he can't
travel back and forth through time he
can only see it and so because of this
it's really interesting here because one
of the things he says is that we're in
the originally when alan scott was a
railroad engineer and had come across
the green lantern the other the actual
answered itself what dr. Manhattan did
is he moved it so that Alan Scott never
came across it and that's kind of a big
deal because what this means is that
because dr. Manhattan cannot travel a
travel through time but because dr.
Manhattan affected the ability for Alan
Scott to become the Green Lantern it
means dr. Manhattan had to have been
there in that moment when that happened
and so it's kind of interesting here
because this this seems to go and seems
to really indicate the dr. Manhattan was
responsible for the creation of the DC
Universe but what Geoff Johns is gonna
do here in a little bit is kind of say
actually he's not and that's that's kind
of the funny thing about this and so
what we end up doing here is picking up
with like Saturn girl and with Johnny
Thunder and with Rorschach and with
Ozymandias again they're all basically
trying to track down dr. Manhattan
that's the real big thing that they're
looking for here and it's kind of an
interesting scenario because what we've
also been seeing kind of going on in the
background is this scenario worse like
the Superman conspiracy right they're
like superheroes are engineered by the
federal government which is why so many
superheroes operate inside the United
States because it's kind of a government
mandated initiative and and so on and so
forth now the other thing about this is
that in the original Watchmen comics
what you had was a character called
Bubastis that was created by created by
Ozymandias i was just kind of like his
attempt to create life more or less but
following the death of that original
Bubastis and his attempt to like destroy
dr. Manhattan wouldn't it up happening
is that Ozymandias created a new version
but instead of this just being being
Bubastis what it is it's really like a
homing beacon it's a device that would
allow him to essentially track down dr.
Manhattan and so like like a radar or
like a you know a radar that might be
plowed or in louder or at a faster
frequency as an object gets closer to it
what this version of Bubastis does is it
kind of lights up a little bit more now
the other part of this is it also picks
up with a comedian remember that also
happened as well and it's kind of cool
to see geoff johns do this where he
brings in the comedian the comedian
assaults like a large majority of the
various villains out of Gotham and then
when like Rorschach and everybody flees
you kind of see what comedian was
in the background by way of like the
news or something along those lines and
so switching directly over to comedian
himself again he's been taken by the
Joker and it's kind of cool to see this
because at the outset you would think
the comedian would have a lot in common
with the Joker - insanity in the sense
of the comedian's very Punisher like in
terms of how he functions or I guess
maybe the Punishers more like the
comedian in terms of how he functions
but the fact remains the Joker is
absolutely insane and the comedian picks
up on that insanity almost immediately
and it's just like let me out of here
get your let me out of here let me go
back and do my thing you know comedians
desire you know Eddie Eddie Blake's
desire just kind of get out of there is
first and foremost but he doesn't
function like a crazy person here and
remember that's the nature of the
comedian the comedian doesn't have the
name because he's a spinoff of the Joker
he has the name because in his mind like
he's not really a tried and true
nihilist he just kind of looks at the
nature of humanity and says the only
thing you can do is laugh about it and
so there are some similarities between
himself and the Joker in that regard he
just lacks the kind of extreme insanity
narcissism and borderline multiple
personality disorder that the Joker has
and so it's kind of interesting but in
the middle of all this they're suddenly
met by the arrival of Batman who's
basically been tracking the comedian now
of course this leads to Batman basically
taking them out only for mime to
basically fire off you know whatever is
invisible guns and seemingly take Batman
by surprise now again it doesn't really
kill him but it is kind of cool to see
Batman facing off against you know these
these characters mime and marionette
characters that he's never seen before
but still when they when they finally
secure the Green Lantern of Allen Scott
what ends up happening is that
Ozymandias basically begins to bring the
two together and it's one of these
things where like they're all kind of
like in a mad dash to the same location
because the cats leading them to a place
and then you have awesome Andy as
following the cat and of course what we
end up finding out here is that where
the Joker's going insane and Batman's
facing them all the cat has been leading
Ozymandias to the comedian and the
reason why is because the cat picks up
on these sort of residues more or less
that better that are there that are left
by dr. Manhattan and so what geoff johns
kind of does is in a roundabout way he
indicates that in some former fashion
dr. Mann had brought Eddie Blake back
that either he brought him back to life
or something along those lines we're not
entirely sure when you end up having
like Ozymandias sort of bringing the cat
and then bringing the the lantern
together and all those different things
one is up happening is you suddenly have
you know essentially dr. Manhattan who
manifests himself and it's kind of crazy
because the way that geoff johns does is
is it almost seemed for an instant that
like dr. Manhattan was pretending to be
the comedian but then of course when
Manhattan's there
you have the comedian sitting in a chair
so of course that wasn't really the case
but it's kind of crazy because Manhattan
you know the the the response of
Ozymandias as we need to talk now at the
outset Batman's responses I know who you
are and it had been kind of cool to see
a little more of an interaction between
the two of them but again Geoff Johns is
a slow build he's a slow burn when it
comes to writing and so you're never
really gonna see like a four-issue arc
were just things just pop off if given
the opportunity Jeff John seems to
always deviate towards telling a longer
story that's more thought-out that has a
lot more dialogue and a lot more plot
building to it which is one of the
things that makes him an excellent
writer you know one of the best comic
book writers to ever live and so dr.
Manhattan grabs them all and just kind
of whisks them away you know how to what
seems like the middle of nowhere and the
responses let's talk let's see what it
is that you have to say and we're
awesome Andy says look you know that the
actual Watchmen world is in shambles you
have to come back and fix things
dr. Manhattan response is no I'm not
going to and this is where geoff johns
kind of says that manhattan didn't
really create the DC universe or at
least it seems to be that case when he
says i left that world for a reason and
i came to this world and so it you know
the the the statement really seems to
indicate dr. Manhattan came to the DC
Universe after the DC Universe had
already come into existence now we don't
know how early he got here dr. Manhattan
kind of sees time and a nonlinear way
and so where we would look at it from
the perspective of well dr. Mann dr.
Manhattan got here like 60 years ago
from his perspective he was just here
and so the way he talks here that's
really kind of the tools and the clues
that geoff johns leaves to us to
determine whether or not manhattan
created everything and saying things
like i was at this point in time i saw
these things take place it all kind of
seems as though dr. Manhattan got here
before superheroes came into existence
but after the after the formation of the
DC Universe so it's kind of a funny
thing because when he starts talking to
marionette when the statements made by
chose to spare you not because I thought
you were a great person who you deserved
it but because you were pregnant and I
saw what your child would go on to do we
know that from her origin story in the
earlier videos and so when the question
is asked well you know what's my child
gonna do Manhattan responds by saying
well which one and then all that's right
you know you don't see time the same way
I do you're pregnant right now that was
kind of interesting the way that John's
writes the character Manhattan he does a
great job doing it but it's very very
difficult for writers to mirror the
style of another writer identical and
when you look at the old alan moore
writing of the watchmen the way he wrote
manhattan was very disconnected but when
you look at manhattan here there's a
hint of anger it seems like he's kind of
eerie
hated or angry with people the other
half of this is that you end up having
like Rorschach who's talking about you
know Ozymandias and saying Ozymandias
has cancer a Manhattan says no he
doesn't you know and that's when
Ozymandias drops the drops his big truth
bomb and says no I never had cancer when
he's talking to Reggie the new Rorschach
he says no I never had cancer I said
that because I needed you and this is
really really really important at that
at the outset it just kind of seems like
man what a dick move but this is
insanely important because what this
means is that it means Ozymandias is
just as manipulative as he ever was that
he saw the opportunity to use Reggie to
use Rorschach for his own ends and took
it and so it means that like in in
reality Ozymandias hasn't changed at all
he's the same person that we saw in the
old Watchmen comics when he thought he
was saving the world and and set this
monster loose in the city of New York
and he's still that same person and
documen hadn't sees that and says to be
the same person you ever worked you know
you are coming here asking me to save a
world that you couldn't save why would I
do that
it's a laboring beast gasping for breath
let that world die and so when you end
up having Reggie kind of freaking out on
on Ozymandias it's interesting because
what Ozymandias says is it's like you
live up to your namesake that you are
really a Rorschach painting you are a
reflection of what you wish to see and
what he says is what you've wanted to
see was that your father in war shaq
were friends what you wanted to see was
that your father was championing
Rorschach's caused and that you were
gonna pick this up as well the reality
of the situation is that war shaq
destroyed everything your father stood
for he destroyed your father's desire to
live a beautiful life he left him as a
fractured broken man you didn't see that
because you didn't want to see that and
it's kind of a crazy scenario because
when you think about that it's it's kind
of mind-boggling they're like Ozymandias
makes these incredible these incredible
observations but then you have Manhattan
who sort of goes back to the old into
the watchman's stories you know where
he's like you know this time is is like
a time is coming when I can't see past
what happens next I can't see the future
beyond this particular point in time and
he doesn't really tell us right off the
bat why that is it's just for some
reason he can't see what's coming later
on down the line and so it seems as
though some bigger threat either from
Manhattan or that will work through
Manhattan kind of seems to be an
indication here and it's kind of crazy
you know when he starts musing about
these things that he's seen how he
spirit how he perceives time how all
this stuff works it really sort of hits
home again and so when you end up having
you know him basically walking away and
just saying I'm done and then just
leaving and then sending everybody back
things just kind of go awry after that
people sort of regain their bearings and
then everything just pops off you have
Batman and Joker
who were dealing with war Shaq beating
the crap out of Ozymandias you've got
mana marionette who take their leave you
got all kinds of crazy stuff happening
here
and so the Joker of course being as it
being as insane as he ever was when you
end up getting out there to to Johnny
Thunder when you get up end up getting
out there to Saturn girl when Ozymandias
shows back up he's been beat to pieces
and so it's just like what in the
world's going on but he starts hiding
his thoughts from Saturn girl so she
can't read his mind just different
things like that and of course he turns
against her and says I have a plan I'm
going to fix everything when he throws
out Johnny Thunder when he throws out
Saturn girl he's like I'm gonna fix
everything I'm gonna solve the problem
of everything and it's kind of crazy
because following this we picked back up
again with dr. Manhattan and what he
says that it would he says is that this
thing that happens in a one month period
basically it's the arrival of Superman
and for some reason Superman is
outrageously pissed and of course this
comes by way of Reggie sending off
information to Lois Lane so that's how
we end up getting Superman into the mix
but the idea is that Superman for some
reason gets it's so astronomically
pissed off that he shows up here he
basically goes to punch dr. Manhattan
and then everything goes black and what
Manhattan II can't figure out here this
is what's so intriguing
what Manhattan cannot figure out here is
if everything goes black because
Superman destroys him with a single
punch or if everything goes black
because he destroys Superman and
everything else and so Jeff Jones leaves
it so ambiguous because if I'm if I'm a
betting man I would bet all the money in
my pockets
- all the money in your pockets which is
zero for me I don't know about you most
likely what's going to happen is if
Superman fought dr. Manhattan Superman
probably wouldn't win you're talking
about a guy who can control the atomic
structure of matter against a guy who
can just punch really hard and so when
you have those things kind of thrown
together it's really kind of an obvious
choice on who's gonna win but we don't
know what state Superman will be in we
don't know if you'll have automated
powers we don't know if Geoff Johns is
gonna amp him up to a higher level than
we've ever seen him before it'll if
it'll be one of those things where Geoff
Johns has Superman pull out all the
mental blocks so he's running on 100%
power and it's just astronomically
insane in terms of what he can do we
don't really know but it's beautifully
done and it's it's it's an amazing way
to leave it because it's just so
intriguing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you